[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whatsa Prof hello Walter hi Martin we're
back to stir a little bit of trouble yes
we're always in trouble but you know
this is probably the most important
place to start this um trouble yes
because if this is not sorted out
there's nothing worth doing for the rest
of time yes this has to be the basis of
everything let's open with a word of
prayer our heavenly father this is such
an important topic we ask that you
please enlighten our minds guide us
through the discussion and also
Enlighten the minds of the viewers in
Jesus name amen amen now m not everybody
will see it this way
no but that's okay yeah like Paul says
maybe one day they'll see it this
way that sounds a bit arrogant but let's
let's go along anyway purified seven
times we're talking about the word of
God the word now the word of God is
essential to us because it is the life
of the world Y and without the word of
God
we wouldn't know even where to
[Music]
begin and the question is what is the
word of
God how do we know that we have the word
of
God so let's talk about these issues
we've done it many times before in
previous whatsapps as well people can
look at the past ones regarding this
topic and you've done very thorough
study and lectures on this in total
Onslaught in quite a few places yes so
yes there are numerous lectures on this
yes but it's a subject that can never be
exhausted exhausted and you know Martin
we could carry on and on and on and go
through Bible verse after Bible verse
and show what the differences are and it
could take us
forever and I don't think that's
necessarily necessary if there's a
really a problem with some of it we
could do that yeah but if people get the
gist of the matter they should be able
to follow and make their own conclusions
as well so let's have a look at this
topic it's going to be a lengthy topic
because it's a it's a hefty
subject let's start with the highest
education that anybody could
have Jeremiah 9 verse 23 thus says the
Lord let not the wise man glory in his
wisdom
neither let the Mighty Man glory in his
might let not the rich man glory in his
riches but let him that glorieth glory
in this that he understandeth and
knoweth me that I am the Lord which
exercises loving kindness judgment and
righteousness in the Earth for in these
things I Delight says the Lord in other
words the Bible says there is nothing as
important as knowing
god that's true now how do you know God
if he doesn't introduce himself to you
if you if there's no way of knowing
getting to know him through any way with
your senses or even reading or nothing
that's right and it's fine to tell us
that Jesus walked the Earth 2,000 years
ago if there's no record of that then
how does that help me 2,000 years later
nothing it doesn't no so it is
absolutely essential that God introduces
himself and that there is a source where
we can get to know him yeah and once we
get into that relationship well then you
going to have experience as well but
experience without the word is a very
dangerous thing because there are other
powers that can give you an experience
as well and those powers know how to
work on the senses
yes they will move your
feelings now M this number seven we
called this thing purified seven times
for a reason we'll come to that this
number seven is very very prominent and
the seven times is also very prominent
if you do a search in the King James you
will find 33 verses where seven times
occurs in that
sequence and 35 places where it occurs
so sometimes more than one in a verse
yeah so this seven times is very
important now we're not going to deal
with 33 verses that deal with seven
times we're looking at one but the
number seven just to get us into the
right frame of mind let's look at some
of the these things where the number is
so prominent the seven promises
to Abraham that were made at the call of
Abraham Genesis
12:1 now the Lord had said unto Abraham
get thee out of thy country and from thy
Kindred and from thy father's house
that's a tall order that's leave
everything behind that you know yes
that's a very tall order into a land
that I will show thee in other words
separate yourself from everything that
you know and I'll take you into
nowhere and I'll teach you about myself
and if you do it this is the
promise I will make thee a great
nation I Will Bless
thee and make thy name great and thou
shalt be a blessing and I will bless
them that bless thee and curse him that
curses thee in thee shall all the
families of the earth be blessed seven
promises yeah they are actually amazing
promises just I will make thee a great
nation yeah he's married to a barren
woman I will bless Thee I will make thy
name
great that thou shalt be a blessing I
will bless them that bless thee and
curse him that curses thee and in thee
shall all families of the earth be
blessed that's a big promise that's a
very big promise but it comes on a
condition yeah get thee out of thy
country separate from thy Kindred and
even from thy Father's House very tall
order all right Revelation 1:3 blessed
is he that readeth and they that hear
the words of this prophecy and keep
those things which are written therein
for the time is at hand so that's the
first blessing you have to study the
book amen
I love the
blessings and then verse 13 in chapter
14 and I Heard a Voice from Heaven
saying right blessed are the dead which
die in the Lord from hence forth yay
says the spirit that they may rest from
their labors and their Works do follow
them so there's the issue of rest and
there's a blessing if you die in the
Lord because you're just sleeping for a
short while there's a lot of information
in that one the first resurrection the
second Resurrection is in there the the
state of the Dead is in there everything
is packed into one little verse chapter
16:1 15 behold I come as a
thief blessed is he that watches and
keepes his garments lest he walk naked
and they see his shame the righteousness
of Christ is that embodied in that oh
for sure so beware that you don't lose
the righteousness of Christ if you don't
there's a
blessing the best blessing of of all is
the promise for the final Hereafter yes
chapter 19:9 and he said unto me blessed
are they which are called unto the
marriage supper of the lamb and he says
unto me these are the true sayings of
God is a marriage supper
coming and if you are called what a
blessing
blessed and holy is he that has part in
the first
resurrection that implies that there's a
second Resurrection where you are not
blessed nor holy yes where you don't
want to be part of you don't want to be
part of it on such the second death has
no power but there shall be Priests of
God and of Christ and shall reign with
him a thousand years there the whole
issue of understanding the the
Millennium
mhm chapter 22 verse 7 behold I come
quickly blessed is he that keeps the
saying of the prophecy of this book
Martin is good enough to read it and
understand it no you have to keep it you
have to keep it
right and are there some things that
you're not supposed to keep like the
mark of the beast for sure yeah you know
want the mark of the beast and blessed
are they that do his Commandments that
they may have the right to the tree of
life and may enter in through the gates
into the city seven blessings well the
seven blessings in Revelation change a
bit if you go to the other translations
but we'll get to that because Revelation
22:14 becomes a totally different thing
and in actual in actual fact it then
repeats the blessing of keeping your
robes that's true so actually then it's
only six there's only six in the new
translation that just shows you we'll
seven times purified yes we need to be
seven times purified we want all seven
right yeah nothing
less Martin there's a little bit of
interference here on the roof what do
you say about that yeah just for in case
it sounds a little bit different we
don't know how bad it is in the
microphone but it's some lovely rain
that is pouring down all right everybody
needs rain so we're also praying for the
latter rain so let's not complain maybe
it's a
foreshadowing 2 Timothy 3:16 all
scripture how much of it ah all all
scripture is given by inspiration of God
and is profitable for Doctrine for
reproof for correction for instruction
in
righteousness modern if you have
different manuscripts and they say the
opposite can both be God breathed no one
of them must be God breathe and one of
them one of them must be spous exactly
one is good for proof of Correction and
instruction the other one is not okay
God committed the preparation of his
divinely inspired word to finite
man this word arranged into books the
old and the New Testament is the guide
book of the inhabitants of a Fallen
World bequeath to them that by studying
and obeying the direction not one Soul
would lose its way to
heaven those are thing to make the
supposed difficulties of scripture plain
in measuring by their finite rule that
which is inspired and that which is not
inspired had better covered their faces
as Elijah did when the still Small Voice
spoke to him for they are in the
presence of God and Holy Angels who for
ages have communicated to men light and
knowledge telling them what to do and
what not to do unfolding before them
scenes of thrilling interest way Mark by
way Mark in symbols and signs and
illustrations this comes from letters
and manuscripts now Martin all this
tells us is don't underestimate
God don't squabble about his
word but it also tells us that if all
scripture is God breathed we must be
sure that we are reading God's word
yes you must make you 100% sure because
otherwise it could be a false god it
could be a false god so all scripture is
given by inspiration there is nothing in
Scripture that is not given by
inspiration Revelation 12:1 17 and the
dragon was wroth with the woman that's
the church and went to make war with the
remnant of her seed which keep the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ is there an
enemy of Christ and the remnant oh yeah
for sure there's an enemy right yeah and
he's a very dangerous foe
yes and he doesn't relinquish very
easily and he doesn't play fair
no and he's angry oh he's very angry he
must be angry for some reason or other
one of the reasons why people get angry
is if they are exposed yeah
right if you catch a thief and you say
you're the one it gets pretty
angry all
right I thought Martin we should talk a
little bit about the law and the
testimony MH because this is a very
important aspect of
scripture what is the law and what is
the
testimony and why is it important
because the Bible tells us that these
two are connected to each other
Psalms 19:7 the law of the Lord is
perfect converting the soul the
testimony of the Lord is sure making
wise the
simple so you have the law and you have
the testimony and they are perfect and
they are essential for
wisdom psalm 78:5 for he established a
testimony in Jacob
and appointed a law in Israel which he
commanded our fathers that they should
make them known to their
children Isaiah
8:16 bind up the testimony seal the law
amongst my
disciples now we dealt with this little
word seal before yeah that means it must
be imprinted it must be burnt in there
it is a sign it is a mark of Your
Allegiance and it must be imprinted in
the
disciples Isaiah 8 verse 20 is a very
important one to the law in this case
it's Torah and the testimony if they
speak not according to this word it is
because there is no light in
them so the Torah is the first five
books of the Bible y it's the law of
Moses it also contains the Ten
Commandments of course
and then the testimony is the testimony
of all the rest the prophets yeah so you
had the law and you had the
testimony if they speak not according to
this word it is because there is no
light in them What If you deny the
word then obviously you're not speaking
according to the word then you have no
light you're in darkness exactly then
whatever you give to other people is
also Darkness so if the Bible says you
were created or the world was created in
six
days and the evolutionists say it was
not created in six days and they have no
light of course not they're in darkness
right John 8:17 it is also written in
your law here he's using the word
nomos that the testimony of two men is
true so you must have more than one
witness right Let each thing be
established by two or three Witnesses
says the Bible you need more than one
witness that's why there are four
gospels for the so that there are
four eyewitness reports of what happened
yeah to make it to make it legal
exactly all right so this word Torah is
a precept or statute especially the
decalog or pentat the
law the word namos means from a primary
word to parcel out especially food or
grazing to animals law through the idea
of prescriptive usage generally a
regulation specifically of Moses
including the volume also of the Gospel
or figuratively a principle a law so
it's similar but it's a little bit
broader yeah has a bit more that's it
pertains to what the scriptures say
whether you're reading in the gospels or
whether you're reading in
Moses so to the law and to the testimony
if they don't speak according to that
word there's no light in them so Mar
basically what we have in the world is a
clash of Minds yeah of
course we have mindsets yeah let's look
at them there are only two religious
systems in the
world only two
there are
many uh organizations but only two
systems not three nor four just
two there is salvation in Christ that
clothes the penitent with the robe of
Christ spotless righteousness that's the
one
yeah or there is salvation by works
which seeks its own righteousness and
circumvents Christ there you go those
are the
two the word of God is the Expositor of
the first
system and the second system negates
this word no more it is at war with this
word is that clear it's 100% clear and
that's what you see in the world all
right now there's a little word in here
that I find
important and that is that the salvation
in Christ clothes the
penitent you have to
repent Whenever there was a a call to
the nation it was repent exactly and be
baptized now repentance means that you
feel sorrow for what you did and make a
covenant not to do it again yes that's
repent
repentance now if your salvation is by
works you can actually
circumvent repentance yeah and we'll see
how this is done in the second system as
we go on
but
repentance is the departure point for
coming into a relationship with Christ
without repentance there is no
relationship is repentance not also the
same as the difference
between in the hand or the forehead
repentance is
both you are convinced yeah and you will
do the right thing yes that's repentance
but you can do the other one like you
mentioned and only do the the action to
go along you can even have it in your
head if it's the wrong one
yeah all right so let's ask a few
questions how does the Catholic view of
Salvation differ from the biblical View
and why does it
differ if so if it does differ how does
this impact the
scriptures now you know it it is
terrible when you think that when you do
a lecture like this it sounds like
Catholic
bashing well but you don't really have a
choice unfortunately because the system
is called Antichrist Antichrist so it's
anti everything that's in the true word
of God right so we're not bashing
Catholics were're bashing the system
exactly and if Catholics could
understand what is going on they would
separate from the system yes they would
have to separate from the system and
everybody else that's Affiliated yes
separate because there's no we saw
there's only two minds only two minds
ETS now when the Reformation took place
the people that separated from
Catholicism were by and large Almost
100% Catholics Catholics yeah
right so we are very grateful to
Catholics we're not against Catholics
we're against a mindset that has been
imprinted in them which is contrary to
scripture yeah so let's have a look at
it it's important that they that we
understand this and that it is the
system that is at fault not the person
because the person doesn't
know so how does the Catholic view of
Salvation differ from the biblical view
now we've already done lectures like the
doctrine of the serpent we've done it in
great detail but for the sake of clarity
and the impact on the word let's just go
through it
again first the why the Catholic view
differs from that of the Bible because
it is dictated by
tradition and not by
scripture many of the fathers of the
church were
gnostics such as Oregon and
eus and once their views became
infallible dogmas they could by
definition not be
changed they are based on Greek
philosophy and not the
Bible now in the system of gnosticism
there is no such thing as that Jesus is
the one Divine human being we're all
basically on the same road we're all on
this path to
Divinity so it denies the exclusive
Divinity of Christ and attribut
attributes the powers to everyone
including all of humanity so that's the
first
difference so how do they differ
Catholic theology denies the
atonement Christ never died for you just
as verily as the other major religions
do it's all one
system they claim you are saved by his
Jesus's good
works and not by his substitutionary
death in the same way the good works of
the Saints and Mary can do the same so
you see they're bringing him to the
level of of man that's
it taken to its logical conclusion then
the Saints and Mary could do it too by
offering to God a gift that is greater
than that which is taken away by the sin
of other individuals an exchange as it
were of something good for something
bad so this is Catholic thinking yeah
and it has a major flaw in it because
basically you can receive something from
other human beings and if you fall short
it can be made up by their good works
it's like a a trade transaction yeah
yeah okay the next point
is Catholic theology denies that Jesus
Paid the price for sin he was just
obedient unto death but not for you
that means that each sinner must pay his
own
price either by going to hell M if his
or her sin is not forgiven or if it is
forgiven by the power invested in the
priest then he or she must still pay the
price before going to
heaven and for this they invented
Purgatory which is a place where you pay
off the price of sin
to alleviate the price to be paid in
purgatory the Church offers a treasury
of
Merit from which indulgences can be
dispensed since both the
forgiven and The Unforgiven are
Eternal they live forever this brings
with it the doctrine of
immortality so you are Immortal if you
are not forgiven you go to hell yeah if
a priest has forgiven you you must still
pay the price for what you did you pay
that price in
purgatory but you can get time off
Purgatory by the pope taking what is in
the treasury of Merit the
meritorious extra works of saints and
Jesus and apply it to
you and uh they made a lot of money with
it because they even sold it for money
that's crazy but this system is alive
and well and living today because the
Pope the present Pope Pope Francis just
offered an Indulgence for all who
listened to his Easter Harmony yeah so
it's the same thing nothing has changed
people always say but Rome has changed
that was the Middle Ages nothing has
changed get it into your heads nothing
has changed it can't because they're
infallible that's it and like you just
mentioned he just did it again he just
did the indulgences yes third Point
Catholic theology teaches that man can
become righteous by his good works
rather than the biblical doctrine of man
receiving the imputed righteousness of
Christ by faith in him salvation in
Catholicism is thus man centered and the
biblical
salvation is Christ
centered Cath theology does not
emphasize
repentance but rather Penance yeah
that's a very important point so M now
you can understand why the Catholic
church can work with organizations like
the mafia for
example because if you do something evil
like killing other people that are in
your way or drug deals or whatever which
is obviously wrong
all you have to do is confess and the
priest forgives it yeah and then you
have to do a Penance yeah but then you
carry on doing what you did before see
so there's no repentance no there's
again it's only a Works based thing is
not a decision correct so basically
there is
no repentance and return to the moral
standard which God has given there are
ways and means to circumvent it to get
round it and this is a very serious
issue so the entire
theology is different from what the
Bible teaches yeah now what if Martin
you are a
organization that is in the eyes of
people supposed to be
biblical then what do you do do you just
bury the Bible or do you change it
if you first try to get rid of it and if
it doesn't work then you change it ah
okay that's very important because this
theology you do not find it in the Bible
let's just make
sure so that people don't think we are
practicing thumbn knowy sucking it out
of our thumb this comes from the
catechism of the Catholic church in
Christ the redemer himself the
satisfaction and merits of his
Redemption
exist and find their
efficacy the
treasury includes as well the prayers
and good works of the Blessed Virgin
Mary they are truly immense unfathomable
and even pristine in their value before
God in the treasury too are the prayers
and good works of all the saints all
those who have followed in the footstep
of Christ the lord and by his grace have
made their lives holy and carried out
the the mission in the unity of the
mystical body so here in this treasury
you find all of these good works and the
pope only has the power to take of this
Merit whether he Scoops marries or a
Saints doesn't make any difference and
applies it to a soul in purgatory and
gives him relief from the time that he
has to spend it's like getting time out
of your jail sentence for your good
behavior but in this case the good
behavior of others it's even more
ridiculous than that there's another web
page called to communion. comom and it's
a the source which gives us a little bit
more detail Merit cannot be
transferred but meritorious acts can
make satisfaction for another by giving
to God a gift of greater value than what
was taken by the sin Martin does that
make any sense to you yeah it's uh well
it's goly goop
right if you I think if you're caught in
this then it must be terrible how scared
you are yes but if you look at it now
knowing that this cannot be true yes
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous yes but
this is what they believe this is how
Christ's own actions in his p passion
and death made satisfaction for the sins
of the whole world there's no blood
involved here but the Bible says without
the shedding of blood there's no
forgiveness of sins so they deny the
atonement
entirely see Catholic and reformed
concepts of the atonement but it is also
the way the meritorious acts of the
Saints can make satisfaction for others
debt of temporal punishment St Thomas
writes all the saints intended that
whatever they did or suffered for God's
sake should be profitable not only to
themselves but to the whole church now
St Thomas is drinking wine and he's
totally
drunk because Martin if you are bad no
matter how good I am I cannot attone for
your evil no you have to make it right
with God that's and this is the major
problem and if this is the Theology of
Catholicism then how does it reflect in
their thinking in their writings and in
their
scriptures in contrast we have letters
in man manuscripts volume Five where it
says I take the Bible just as it is as
the inspired word I believe its
utterances in an entire entire Bible men
arise who think they find something to
criticize in God's word they lay it be
before others as evidence of superior
wisdom these men are many of them smart
men learned men they have eloquence and
talent the whole life work of whom it is
to unsettle Minds in regard to the
inspiration of
scriptures they influence many to see as
they do and the same work is passed on
from one to another just as Satan
designed it should be until we may see
the full meaning of the words of Christ
when the son of man cometh shall he find
faith on the earth Brethren let not a
mind or hand be engaged in criticizing
the Bible it is the work that Satan
Delights to have any of you do but it is
not a work the Lord has pointed out for
you to do you must read the Bible as it
stands yeah Martin I want to make sure I
read the right Bible correct because I
want to know what God
Said men should let God take care of his
own book his living
oracles as he has done for ages they
begin to question some parts of
Revelation and pick flaws in their
parent
inconsistencies of this statement and
that statement beginning at Genesis they
give up that which they deem question
able and their minds lead on for Satan
will lead to any length they may follow
in their criticism and they see
something to doubt in the whole
scriptures their faculties of criticism
become sharpened by exercise and they
can rest on nothing with a certainty you
try to reason with these men but your
time is lost they will exercise their
power of ridicule even upon the Bible
they even become mockers and they would
be astonished if if you put it to them
in that light Brethren cling to your
Bible as it reads and stop your
criticism in regard to its validity and
obey the word and not one of you will be
lost the Ingenuity of men has been
exercised for ages to measure the word
of God by their finite minds and limited
comprehension if the Lord the author of
The Living oracles would throw back the
curtain and reveal his WI wisdom and His
glory before them they would shrink into
nothingness and exclaim as did Isaiah
I'm a man of unclean lips and I dwell
Amit the people of unclean lips Isaiah
6:5 I just spoke to a man
recently who tried to convince me that
most of what in the stands in the Bible
is incorrect M has been written by
Infidel men you through out all the
writings of Paul
and now he wants to find a basis on
which to debate the existence of God he
just remov the basis yeah what are we
going to talk on nothing right nothing
and then whenever you mention something
else oh no that's not meant like that
and that doesn't fit in there no and
this shouldn't have written been written
like this and this verse shouldn't be
there Etc so we need to be very very
careful how we approach this subject so
let's start this discussion although
we've already started
it with uh Psalms 12 uh the King James
gives it the heading the faithful have
vanished help
Lord interesting it's a cry for The
Godly Man
ceaseth for the faithful fail from
amongst the children of men they speak
vanity everyone with his neighbor with
flattering lips and with a double heart
do they speak the Lord shall cut off all
flattering lips and the tongue that
speaketh proud things didn't we just
speak about the little horn power yeah
does it say proud things oh yes Blas and
proud is almost
Blasphemous definitely
Blasphemous who have said with our
tongue will we Prevail our lips are our
own who is the Lord over us we shall
decide the path of salvation not you for
the oppression of the poor for the
sighing of the needy now will I arise
says the Lord I will set him in safety
from him that puffeth at him now the
poor and the needy here or the poor in
spirit that have been
starved of the word of Truth yeah now
two very important verses verse six the
words of the Lord are pure words
as silver tried in the furnace of Earth
purified seven
[Music]
times and the next verse Thou shalt keep
them oh Lord Thou shalt preserve them
from this generation
Forever This is the King
James so in the King James it tells us
that the words of the Lord are pure they
are purified seven times and that the
Lord will keep them the
words and shall preserve them from this
generation forever yeah so he promises
he
promises in other translation the
preservation goes to humanity and not to
the word so this is very important can
God expect me to keep his word if he
never preserved his word no because how
would you know what to do exactly so I
always say
inspiration without preservation is
useless it is so God you cannot expect
me to keep your word if you haven't
given me your word and therefore if your
words are pure and they're tried in the
in the furnace seven times and you've
promised to preserve them then I must
still be able to find them for sure okay
that is a promise Psalms 12:8 says the
wicked walk on every side when the viest
men are exalted it looks like reading
the news these
days that's true very much so yeah so in
this world the vest of men are exalted M
and uh the word of the Lord is put aside
and wicked is on every
side okay Martin where do we get our
Bibles from and what do we do with them
now the interesting thing is there are
basically two
streams they are divided into three but
basically two of them are the same there
are two
streams so you have when it comes to the
New Testament
originally you have manuscripts which
are no longer available so these
manuscripts were written by the Bible
writers themselves that's the
apostles and
Paul they wrote the scriptures and Mark
also
contributed now those original hand
written documents are no longer
available obviously they were copied
many
times Faithfully kept in a place and
copied and copied and copied so we have
copies of copies but we don't have the
original ones that's just as well as you
scanned the original into your computer
and you just print the copies of it
though correct so let's say that the
original manuscripts are lost but we
have thousands of
copies now you have two streams the one
is the alexandrian
family and the original ones are also
lost and then you have the ancestors of
the western family and the originals are
also
lost okay now the western family that
simply means those manuscripts which
were largely kept in Western Europe and
those manuscripts and the alexandrian
manuscripts are basically part of one
family okay okay so let's have a look at
them now in this ancestra of the
alexandrian family we have a couple of
manuscripts that are available and those
are Papyrus 75 comes from about 200 ad
you have another Papyrus which also
comes from that time period and then you
have codex B and you have codex
Al now these two are very very important
in the world
today and they come from the 4th
century and they say that these are the
oldest existing documents of the New
Testament yeah all right they also
contain the Old Testament
the ALF was found in
Sinai so this is the
cicus and this one is the vaticanus
because it was found in the Vatican
library and from these two documents
largely we have all the modern versions
like the revised version the American
Standard Version the revised Standard
Version and the new English Bible and
all the others the NIV Etc all come from
this
stream earlier than
that this Western
stream the old Latin vgate there was an
old Latin version and then there was the
Latin Vulgate and then there was codex D
codex D2 codex e and from that they had
the daa version of
1582 which is the Jesuit version of the
Bible and man scripts belonging to the
same family have the same text and they
agree closely in wording these two
streams the alexandrian and the Western
are basically what comprise the
scripture as preserved by Catholicism
okay the Latin Vulgate is the one that
the papacy has declared
infallible all right now it's also
interesting that of course in the Dua
version it is not uh the Messiah that
crushes the head of the serpent no but
it is Mary that crushes the head of The
Serpent and the same you will find in
the Vulgate so there is something there
which is very strange to begin with yeah
and then you have the what the stream
that led to the King James version where
you had the gothic versions you had the
syc the pita you have codex W which is
the Matthew and the Codex a and then the
vast majority of extent and New
Testament scriptures and there are
thousands and thousands of manuscripts
at least 5,000 if not more more than
enough Witnesses and they all
correspond now this stream is called the
Eastern stream the middle one this one
and it was uh in Antioch which was in
Syria M where the Christians were first
called
Christians and the manuscripts were kept
at
Antioch so the disciples Paul and the
disciples the manuscripts were stored
there so the other stream is the one
that the Vatican lays claim
to and out of that comes the King James
version now all the original manuscripts
are lost so some of these manuscripts
come out of the fifth century copies of
copies of copies of copies that's why it
always looks as if but there are many
many transcripts which are all in
harmony yeah so they say that these ones
that come out of the fourth Century like
the cicus and the vaticanus that they
are older and then they say older is
better but it cannot be but it not
necessarily so because the were found in
very questionable environments in Waste
Paper baskets and hidden in a library so
nobody had ever had access to them but
this stream everybody had access to
because there were thousands of copies
exactly and it's much broader spread out
over the Earth all right now let's have
a look at this issue now one of the
great Scholars of the
post-reformation period was uh Dean ber
yeah now he speaks about the character
of the two so-called oldest
manuscripts and this is of course the
cicus and the
vaticanus he says of these two the
impurity of the text exhibited by these
codices is not a question of opinion but
of fact in the gospels alone codex B the
Vatican leaves out words or whole
clauses
no less than
1,491 times it Bears traces of careless
transcription on every page CODIS cicus
abounds with errors of the I and Pen to
an extent not indeed unparalleled but
happily rather unusual in documents of
First Rate
importance so he says the documents are
it's horrendous yeah it's not even
accurate copies correct
he continues and says on many occasions
10 20 30 40 words are dropped through
very carelessness letters and words even
hold sentences or frequently written
twice over or begun and immediately
cancelled while that gross blunder
whereby a clause is omitted because it
happened to end in the same words as the
Clause precedings occurs no less than
115 times in the New Testament this
comes from Les Garett which Bible can we
trust so these
two uh Bas of the modern Bible versions
yeah that's now the vaticanus and the
cus yes these two are very garbled
documents and by the way the vaticanus
doesn't even it has the whole Bible it
doesn't have Genesis and it doesn't have
Revelation and of course the cicus and
the vaticanus contain the Apocrypha M
and we need to talk about that as well
including the Epistle of Barnabas in the
cicus which has such ridiculous
statements as that the hyena gives birth
through the mouth and changes its sex
and then it has the statement that when
Christ came out of the Grave he couldn't
even walk so two angels supported him
and the cross was walking behind him by
itself you know pathetic things like
this and this is supposed to be an ocean
of Purity yeah and then this is supposed
to be scripture like we've read earlier
the word of God yeah and the God all God
breath and will be preserved all right
you said it mentions that the hyena
gives birth but it was the weasel I
think the weasel yeah yes but uh the
hyena changes six after after the birth
so ridiculous statements like this now
the Bible the the central
one from which we get the King James
version is a very interesting one and we
have to talk about where exactly that
came from and how it came into existence
now if you go to Psalms 12 which we just
read a little while ago verse 6 says the
words of the Lord are pure words as
silver tried in a furnace of Earth
purified seven times
now William Tindle in his
1525 version published the New
Testament Genesis through two Chronicles
and Jonah were translated but published
separately not as a Bible Tindle
translated as much as possible from
Greek and Hebrew rather than the Latin
as wickliff did wili's translation was
not a
purification as it was translated solely
from the corrupted Latin Vulgate now
let's just talk about that a little
bit where did these manuscripts come
from now during the you mean now the
ones in the middle of our um yes the
ones that the that the King James is
based
upon Martin we have to we have to think
about this issue in great seriousness so
Rome had had all its Authority based
upon the Latin Vulgate by Jerome we have
to ask ourselves where did that come
from yeah and how did it become the
authoritative Bible of the Roman
Catholic
Church the Eastern churches they had
another stream the so-called receive
text yes now that text doesn't have the
original documents anymore but there are
translations of that which are very old
yeah for example
Armenia had a translation into their
language which is also fourth Century MH
and which is in complete harmony with
this received
text the other thing that's very
interesting even though there aren't old
documents there are many letters from
early church
fathers that quote these texts first
century second century 2 century and
from the quotes alone you can almost put
together the whole new testament and the
interesting thing is those quotes are
all in harmony with the received text
not with and not with the ex alexandrian
or Western ver versions and by the way
those were all discovered in the desert
Hidden Away by the sands of time
4,500 years these are now the cicus and
those ones yes all of those documents on
which those two streams uh that make up
the Catholic versions were hidden from
Humanity now would God hide his word
from Humanity for 1,500 years no because
he that or was that word available all
the time it had to be preserved because
he says that you cannot go a day without
him all right
so what was available in the West Was
Written in a dead language Latin and it
remained buried as far as Humanity was
concerned and all the people were fed
were the traditions of the church now
how did the other manuscripts come into
the hands of the early
reformers the received text the received
text how did they get hold of those
manuscripts which were written in Greek
and not in
Latin what happened is is that
turkey the Ottoman Empire had taken over
the East and the Turks attacked
Constantinople and the Greek Scholars
fled for their lives with their
manuscripts to the West in the time of
the
reformation and here A whole host of
documents on the received text
came into Western
hands and these documents were then
recorded and there was a theologian in
the Catholic Church Erasmus of Rotterdam
he cated these documents and set up a
translation in Greek the Greek test New
Testament and the reformers got hold of
these documents and they based their
translations on these documents now
William tile is the first one in
1525 to actually use these documents the
Greek version of the New Testament to
publish his new testament the previous
ones that were available were wickliff
for example yeah now wickliff used the
vgate that's it that and there at least
2,000 errors that even the papacy had
corrected after declaring it infallible
which is very very strange if you come
to think of it so the first real pure
word if the received text can be seen as
such was the one that William Tindle
used okay but he didn't have all the
manuscripts so he still borrowed a
little bit here and there from the Latin
manuscripts now there were other Latin
manuscripts the old Latin Bible is in
harmony with the received text not to be
confused with the Vulgate no just
explain what the Vulgate means the
Vulgate means in the vulgar tongue so in
the Latin that was spoken in the time of
the r common language common language
that is what Jerome translated but we'll
get to those details later so the first
word that was translated into English
was that by William Tindle where he used
largely these manuscripts that had come
from the East and he used some others as
well and then there was an improvement
made because Tindle never finished the
work yeah they strangled him because he
was a Catholic priest so they didn't
burn him alive like they did with the
others for this terrible job that he did
of translating the Bible from the Greek
manuscripts into English
now that work wasn't complete so the
second attempt was by Miles Coverdale in
1535 he published the first complete
English Bible the Coverdale built on
Tindle work and yet translated also from
the German and Latin but not completely
from the original language so there was
an improvement but it wasn't perfect yet
yeah cavel and Tindle at times worked on
this translation
together the third one was John Rogers
now Tindle had been killed so in
1537 using the pen name of Thomas
Matthew he published the Matthew Bible
which combined the best of Tindle and
coverdale's work and John Rogers also
finished what Tindle couldn't complete
because of his early death
the interesting thing is they also
grabbed John Rogers and tied him to the
steak and burnt him as well as well
yeah the fourth attempt to improve the
word or to get to the real intent of
what God had said is the great Bible of
1539 and this was completed by Miles
cavel and called the great Bible because
of its large size
this Bible used Tindle unfinished Old
Testament books which were translated
from the Latin
vgate and German translations rather
than the original Greek and Hebrew okay
the great Bible was also called The Wit
church Bible after its first English
printer The Cromwell Bible after the one
who prepared it for publication the crma
Bible after the preface by crma or the
change Bible since it was changed in a
convenient place for people to read in
the churches so that was the fourth
attempt to get a complete document from
the original Greek
manuscripts then the fifth
attempt the Geneva Bible of 1560 this
was the first Bible to be translated
completely from the original texts just
for interest s Martin in this in this
attempt
to get the Bible to be completely from
the original text they also used venan
versions Ah that's what I wanted to ask
earlier when did the
venian stream come into place yes here
in Geneva they used I think it was eight
if I remember correctly uh versions of
the valencians as well so just to make
people if they don't know the valencians
were in the Swiss and French Alps
correct so William Whittingham miles
Coverdale Christopher Goodman Anthony
gilby Thomas Samson William Cole John
Knox John Calvin participated in this
translation it was very popular because
it was a study Bible with maps and cross
references and was small small enough to
be used for home
study uh another interesting thing about
this particular Bible the Geneva Bible
is that it had footnotes and
explanations because it was a study
Bible and they would call a spade a
spade so when they talked about the
prophecies for example of Daniel they
would say who the little horn was but
because John Knox and Calvin were
involved there were also calvinistic
footnotes m and there wasn't always
agreement in the religious world with
the ideas of Calvin particularly with
regard to
predestination and so although it was a
very popular bible and became the
Standard Bible for
Protestants it had some of these
footnotes which some
deemed problematic of course another
thing about this Bible it was written in
an older English Okay so it wasn't n in
the Modern English it was more like
Cha's English so today it would be very
hard to
read so a six version the so-called
Bishop's Bible was published in
1568 it was translated by Matthew Parker
Archbishop of Canterbury and his fellow
Bishops because there was no supervisor
the translation practice varies greatly
from book to book they also removed the
calvinistic margin notes of the Geneva
Bible so there were some changes made
yeah and then finally the seventh
version was the King James version of
1611 this was the seventh
purification based on the Greek
manuscripts right that's it so God's
promises to preserve his pure word now
we have to we have to test this to see
whether this is really so what
interesting about the King James version
is the way in which the translation took
place it was sanctioned by the king yeah
King James and the Parliament was of
course run by the
Protestants and it was a joint
parliamentary decision to publish this
Bible and there was great opposition
against it from the Roman Catholic side
I believe it because previously they
killed the people to which did yes now
the way in which they did this was
unique they set up different cell
groups uh if I remember correctly I'm
speaking of the top of my head it was
six
groups consisting of a number of men and
they would pass a verse through and
these would translate it now they were
situated in different parts of the
country the various
groups and each group would then come to
a consensus as to to the exact
translation of what was
actually there so it's a direct
translation direct translation of the
original yes and if the group accepted
it and had consensus then that version
was sent to all the other groups and
they all put their input in that and
when they reached consensus across the
entire board then they would open it up
to the other the loans and people in
universities Etc to give their opinions
and only if there was absolute consensus
was it accepted this was never done
before in this fashion and it cuts out
many of the of the problems of
individual bias true because it is
covered by different people different
places and it shows you exactly what
stood in the original correct and there
was so much opposition from the Catholic
side against this version because it of
course negated many of the errors that
were in the vgate yeah well even the
papacy had 2,000 corrections made
right and this really infuriated them
and so they made a decision to destroy
the entire committee plus the Parliament
that sanctioned it plus the king and
blow them to smithin in the parliament
yeah and Guy Fox was the Jesuit trained
individual who was given the task of
destroying the entire system so that it
and the Bible would be removed with one
blow the entire Protestant government
plus the king that sanctioned it plus
the translation should go yeah now that
plot failed on the 5th of November mhm
guy fox day which is an interesting date
so this is how this one came into
existence and where the manuscripts
actually came from so actually God
promised it will be preserved it will be
purified and exactly through not having
that blown up session already also shows
that yes God prevented that from
happening now the VOR churches which or
the venian which were in the in the Alps
or also on the French side resembled the
Church of the apostolic
times rejecting the supremacy of Pope
and prelate they held the Bible as the
only infallible Authority their pastors
unlike the lordly priests of Rome fed
the flock of God leading them to Green
Pastures and living Fountains of his
holy word the people assembled not in
magnificent churches or grand Cathedrals
but in the Alpine valleys or in time of
danger in some rocky stronghold to
listen to the words of truth from the
Servants of Christ the pastors not only
preached the gospel they visited the
sick and labor to promote Harmony and
Brotherly Love Like Paul the Tent Maker
each learned some trade by which if
necessary to provide for his own support
the religious belief was founded upon on
the written word of God those humble
peasants shut away from the world had
not by themselves arrived at truth in
opposition to the dogmas of the apostate
Church their religious belief was their
inheritance from their fathers they
contended for the faith of the apostolic
church the church in the wilderness and
not the proud hierarchy enthroned in the
great world Capital it was the True
Church of Christ the guardian of the
treasures of Truth which God committed
to his people to be given to the world
and it's interesting that their
documents were based on the received
text true so they had the same doctrines
and truths that the apostles had correct
so according to this quote it is they
that traced their lineage all the way
back to the apostles and they had the
true word of God and they were the
Protectors of the word so Rome Martin
would want you to believe that they are
the ones who gave the world the
scripture but here has a different line
a different source of scriptures now
when Rome in its
councils decided which books were
canonical M they added the apocryphal
books now let's talk about that for a
while yeah the Canon of the Old
Testament was complete 400 years before
Christ yeah complete it was written over
a period of more than a thousand years
and it was complete 400 years before
Christ apocryphal books were added later
yeah and the apocryphal books often
differ in theology from the canonical
books that were complete the Old
Testament the New Testament was complete
in the first 100 years after Christ yes
and it was complete when the Apostle
John had died those manuscripts were
available and the Roman Catholic Church
never existed at that stage so they had
nothing to do with the cannon of the Old
Testament neither did they have anything
to do with the Canon of the New
Testament the apocryphal books of the
New Testament were written some two
Century in the second century to the 4th
Century so they came later yeah and they
were added and the Roman Catholic Church
decided that the apocryphal books were
to be canonical yes so that's their
contribution to the Bible in other words
a
sparus information that contradicts the
original documents true and most of it
is there to support their doctrines to
support their Doctrine and that's why
they want the apocryphal books but they
never gave the world the Bible ever yeah
so that is the status quo of where the
King James came from now how this all
affects this war on the word and which
is now the true word the line that came
through the Protestant yeah or the line
that came through the
papacy the alexandrian line from the
second century on through Alexandre
through
gnosticism through Jerome to the gate to
the Catholic
manuscripts or from Apostolic times all
the way through the venian and later
these Eastern manuscripts when the Turks
invaded came to the west and those
manuscripts were used by the reformers
and the question
is did God give the reformers spous
manuscripts he he couldn't would he have
given them the vgate that had so many
errors would he have given them the two
manuscripts that were hidden in the
desert sands and in libraries for more
than a thousand years depriving Humanity
of the scriptures or would he have given
those documents of which there are
thousands of copies which are in
agreement and given it to the reformers
purified it and said to the church here
is the true word of God on which to base
your religion
that is what we need to study so let's
continue in a second session to talk
about these things because it's a little
bit of a broad of a mouthful so let's
pray Heavenly Father help us to unravel
this mystery and to receive Clarity on
what saith the Lord in Jesus name amen
[Music]